This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English to show that brings you an interesting topic,
authentic listening practice and vocabulary to help you improve your language skills.
I'm Dan. And I'm Catherine.
In this programme we'll be discussing Mermaid's as well as teaching you six new items of vocabulary, of course.
How would you like to be a mermaid?
A half human and half fish. Well Dan, I think it's all a myth.
Well then you'll find this week's question a bit of a difficult one to answer.
I suppose I will. Go on then.
When did the most recent alleged mermaid sighting take place?
Was it A, the 1400s, B, the 1800s or C, the 2000s?
Okay and by alleged or alleged you mean said or believed to be true but not proven.
I don't believe in mermaids but I think there's a lot of people who do.
So I will say C, the 2000s.
Well we'll find out if you're right a bit later on.
So what do you know about mermaid's Catherine?
Well a mermaid is a creature that's similar in appearance to a woman but instead of legs
a mermaid has the tail of a fish. The males are called Mermaid and they live in the ocean.
I thought they were a myth.
Well they certainly appear to be mythical.
They feature in legends and stories from all over the world.
The earliest known one in this story dates from ancient Assyria around 1000 BC.
Can you think of a more modern example?
Many people will be familiar with the Disney story with the Little Mermaid.
Yes but before it was an animated movie it was renowned fairy tale written by Hans Christian Anderson
first published in 1837. Interestingly a small bronze statue of the Little Mermaid has been sitting
in Copenhagen in Denmark since 1913.
There you go there's no real evidence.
What if I told you that over 200 mermaids have recently gathered in Greensboro,
North Carolina in the USA?
You're telling me fish tails Dan.
Okay I'll confess they aren't real mermaids.
Each person is a normal human wearing a waste high latex tail.
They meet to share an interest in aquatic mythology, take underwater photos and swim.
For many of them it's a source of income too.
Listen to Daniel Craig five year merman explain.
A lot of the mermaids we have attending here are professional mermaids.
They will entertain at birthday parties, social events,
company events.
I stumbled across the mermaiding community nearly by accident.
So it's a job too a professional merman.
And Daniel said that he stumbled across it or found it by accident.
So it doesn't really count then though does it Dan?
A real real mermaid?
That's a different kettle of fish which is an idiomatic phrase that means
a completely different matter or issue.
Well while we have no hard evidence such as a photo of a real mermaid,
there have been several sightings.
One of the more recent ones was in 2009 in Haifa Bay.
Hang on now that rings a bell, that's in Israel isn't it?
And it allegedly appeared at sunset.
Apparently the mermaid was doing tricks.
There you go then.
But there is no reason done to believe that that was anything other than a hoax,
which means a deception or a lie, often done for humour or sometimes cruelty.
Well real or not, it could be quite fun to be a mermaid.
I wonder what it would be like.
Well that I can help with.
Let Daniel Craig explain why he likes it so much.
It's just serene.
It's the perfect place for a temporary getaway.
So he likes it because it's serene which means calm and peaceful.
Yes and he says it's the perfect getaway,
which is a place you go in order to escape from normal life.
Well I still don't believe in mermaids,
but I do believe Dan that you asked me a question.
I definitely did.
I asked when did the most recent alleged mermaid sighting take place?
Was it A the 1400s, B the 1800s or C the 2000s?
And I said I think it was the 2000s.
And you have hit the nail on the head well done.
Thank you.
Exactly right it was the 2000.
It was in 2012 in Zimbabwe and it was reported by the water resource minister.
Let's take a look at the vocabulary from this program.
Our first word was alleged or alleged.
If something is alleged it is said or believed to be true but not proven to be true.
Can you think of a recent example, Catherine?
US President Donald Trump has alleged that newspapers have been printing fake news.
Apparently there's no proof.
And our next one was stumbled across.
So if you stumble across something you encounter or find it by accident.
It's a phrasal verb and you could also say come across.
So Dan, have you ever stumbled across anything unusual?
Well there was a time when I was going to a party in Holborn and I got completely lost
and there on the floor in front of me I stumbled across a map of London.
It got me straight to the party.
Spooky.
The next one after that was a different kettle of fish.
A different kettle of fish is an idiomatic phrase which means a completely different matter
or issue.
You could also use the phrase a horse of a different colour.
Next up we had hoax and a hoax is a deception or lie
which is often done for humour or cruelty.
What was the last hoax you did, Dan?
One Christmas I wrapped a broken light bulb in a box
and gave it to my mother as a present.
I pretended to drop it and the broken light bulb make a glass shattering noise
and she thought that I had broken her present.
After that we heard serene.
Serene means calm and peaceful.
The noun is serenity.
What's your idea of serene Catherine?
Two weeks lying on the beach, drinking lemonade,
listening to the sound of the sea.
Fabulous.
And finally we had a getaway.
A getaway is an informal word meaning a place you go in order to escape from normal life
such as a holiday.
So where's your favourite getaway, Dan?
My favourite getaways my yoga class.
I find it really, really refreshing.
Well that's the end of today's six minute English.
Please join us again soon.
I'm a Ron social media too so make sure to visit us on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram and YouTube.
Bye bye.
English from the BBC.